>>> JUST IN TIME FOR TODAY'S
OFFICIAL START OF INCOME TAX
FILING SEASON.
THE IRS IS WARNING YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO WAIT LONGER TO GET YOUR
REFUND.
GABE REPORTS FOR US NOW.
THE COVID PANDEMIC, BACKLOG OF
RETURNS FROM LAST YEAR, AND A
WORKER SHORTAGE MAY ADD UP TO
LONG DELAYS FOR YOU.
>> A WARNING FROM THE IRS.
EXPECT ANOTHER FRUSTRATING TAX
FILING SEASON MARKED BY
PROCESSING PROBLEMS AND REFUND
DELAYS.
THE AGENCY IS IN CRISIS, FACING
A BACKLOG OF CLOSE TO 10 MILLION
RETURNS.
>> WE'RE WORKING AS HARD AS WE
CAN.
>> NOW DEALING WITH NEW STAFFING
PROBLEMS FROM COVID AND WAGE
COMPETITION.
WITH NEARLY 200 JOB OPENINGS
POSTED ON THEIR WEBSITE ON TOP
OF A LONG LIST OF OTHER ISSUES
LIKE OUTDATED SOFTWARE, TEDIOUS
PAPER FILINGS AND MOST NOTABLY,
A LACK OF SUFFICIENT FUNDING.
SINCE 2010, THE NUMBER OF TAX
RETURNS IS UP 19%, BUT THE
AGENCY'S FUNDING AND STAFFING
ARE DOWN CLOSE TO 20%.
>> I THINK IT BOILS DOWN TO
FUNDING.
>> JOHN WAS IRS COMMISSIONER
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> IF YOU HAVE TO CALL OR
RESPOND TO A NOTICE FROM THE
IRS, THAT'S WHEN THE PROBLEMS
BEGIN.
>> LAST YEAR, THE IRS ONLY
ANSWERED 11% OF CUSTOMER CALLS.
WITH MANY WAITING HOURS TO GET
THROUGH.
MEANWHILE, TAX FILING IS GETTING
MORE COMPLICATED IN THE PANDEMIC
WITH NEW PROGRAMS AROUND COVID
RELIEF AND CHILD TAX CREDITS.
TRAFFIC TO THE IRS NEARLY
TRIPLED IN 2020 AND ROSE AGAIN
LAST YEAR.
NOW MILLIONS OF TAXPAYERS ARE
STILL WAITING FOR THEIR REFUND.
>> IT'S BEEN FRUSTRATING.
>> PAUL AND HIS FAMILY NEED THAT
$7,000.
HE'S ON DISABILITY AND HIS WIFE
RUNS A SMALL BUSINESS.
>> KNOWING THAT IT'S OUT THERE
AND WE CAN'T ACCESS IT AND WE
COULD REALLY USE THAT MONEY
RIGHT NOW IS A CHALLENGE.
>> I THINK IT'S URGENT.
>> THE BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN
WOULD INCLUDE $80 BILLION TO
STRENGTHEN THE IRS, BUT WITH THE
BILL STALL NDED IN THE SENATE,
WHITE HOUSE IS NOW CALLING ON
CONGRESS TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
>> THE AGENCY HAS NOT BEEN
EQUIPP
EQUIPPED WITH THE RESOURCES IT
NEEDS.
>> EVERYONE'S STUCK.
>> JANICE RETURNS A LOW INCOME
TAXPAYERS CLINIC IN MARYLAND.
THEY'VE SEEN A HUGE SPIKE IN
DEMAND.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO HELP THESE
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS, BUT WE
CAN'T ALWAYS GET ANSWERS EITHER
FROM THE IRS.
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY STRESSFUL.
>> JASMINE JONES IS DAYS AWAY
FROM DELIVERING HER THIRD CHILD
AND SHE'S BEEN WAITING FOR HER
$11,000 REFUND SINCE BEFORE SHE
WAS PREGNANT.
>> AND WE HAVE RACKS AND RACKS
OF BILLS TO CATCH UP ON.
>> TO AVOID DELAYS THIS SEASON,
THE IRS IS URGING PEOPLE TO FILE
EARLY AND ELECTRONICALLY, USE
DIRECT DEPOSIT, MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING'S ACCURATE.
ESPECIALLY WITH STIMULUS
PAYMENTS AND THE CHILD TAX
CREDITS ALL TO AVOID A
FRUSTRATING WAIT.
>> IT MAKES ME THINK I WON'T
RECEIVE IT THIS YEAR.
>> AS TAX SEASON GETS UNDERWAY
TODAY, AGAIN, THE IRS SAYS FILE
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THE DEADLINE FOR M